some sad news to report for BLM fans
black lives matter co-founder Patrice
colors has been released from her Warner
Brothers deal meaning that she will no
longer produce any BLM focused scripted
or non-scripted content
now In fairness to Warner Brothers
Patrice colors never produced any
content whatsoever during the term of
her deal she she just got a lot of money
and and didn't make anything
but In fairness to Colors no one ever
really expected her to make anything in
the first place
Patrice colors has never created
anything in her whole life
BLM did not exist to create things BLM
existed to destroy
and to extort money from corporations
and to enrich the activists who ran it
so that they could buy large Mansions
BLM Patrice colors is Hollywood
development deal was just one of many
payoffs that she and the BLM leaders
received from Industries all around the
country
and everyone got what they wanted
everyone don't feel sorry for Warner
Brothers colors made money the
corporations signaled their fealty to
the left and the Liberals broadly gained
more power and now on to the next scam
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
the first day of Pride it's the first
day of the most holy month of the
liturgical year according to liberals
pride month every industry is going gay
for pride
including the abortion industry Planned
Parenthood has just come out with its
own
Pride campaign
to point out that abortion is not just
for women we'll get to that in just a
little bit first though we have some
breaking news and the breaking news
actually is coming from inside the house
the breaking news is coming from here at
Daily wire Jeremy boring the god king of
this joint has has just released news on
Twitter
that Twitter has canceled a deal to
Premiere what is a woman for free on the
platform and the reason they've canceled
the deal is because of two instances in
what is a woman at this movie that was
released one year ago today I think uh
two instances of misgendering
misgendering of course means gendering
misgendering is when you call a man he
and a woman she instead of calling a man
she and a woman he
not surprising in our broader culture it
is somewhat surprising on Twitter the
whole point of the Elon Musk acquisition
of Twitter at least from The public's
perspective is that we were finally
going to have free speech and we weren't
going to left these wokey leftists come
in here and tell us we have to call boys
girls and girls boys we're going to kick
us off of the platform for stating basic
truths and now
Twitter is canceling our premiere of
what is a woman the idea was that as the
rest of the the social media companies
are really clamping down on I won't even
call it conservative speech Just
clamping down on reality
Twitter was going to give us the
opportunity to to speak freely that's
why we just announced in recent days
that we're going to bring the shows
including my show to Twitter now we're
we're gonna really start using this
platform and we thought what better way
to do it Tucker announced that he was
going to bring his show to Twitter okay
this is great and we're going to allow
everybody the whole public to watch what
is a woman for free on the platform on
this day on this anniversary
so well I'll just read from Jeremy's
thread I don't want to misrepresent what
happened here
so we're going to give it away for 24
hours that was the plan
and we were talking to Twitter Twitter
responded with enthusiasm offered us the
opportunity to buy a package to host the
movie on a dedicated event page to
promote the event to every Twitter user
for the first 10 hours okay we here at
Daily wire accepted that agreement we
signed the agreement Twitter then said
okay well we just want to see the movie
so we're better prepared to to help with
this event they watched the movie
and then
they killed the deal
they said that that not only could
Twitter no longer help us to host this
movie for free for everybody
but they were actively going to suppress
the movie
they said they were going to limit the
reach of the movie now
for hateful conduct and they
specifically cited as an example of this
hateful conduct
misgendering so at that point we at the
daily wire came back and said well hold
on a second you you've come out and said
that you're no longer going to make
misgendering this this suppressible
offense you're no longer going to send a
sensor misgendering which is just proper
gendering
remember you took that out of your out
of your Community guidelines and then
Twitter came out and said well yeah okay
they were we removed the misgendering
prohibition from the policy but that's
just because we at Twitter didn't want
to be that specific but misgendering so
contradicting transgender ideology is
not is still considered abuse and
harassment by Twitter and then Twitter
you want to hear the audacity of these
guys
Twitter came out and said well if you
edit the movie if you edit one of the
biggest documentaries ever one of the
most important films of last year if you
edit it and you don't call men him and
women her
then maybe we'll allow you to host this
event with us on Twitter
so we said no we're not doing that we're
not editing what the hell is the point
of the purchase of Twitter if we're
going to do that I'll put it on any of
the other social media sites who openly
say they're going to suppress me you
don't pretend to be bastions of free
speech
and then they said okay well you have
the right to speak but we're basically
we're going to make sure that no one
hears you
which Jeremy points at is like saying
hey you've got the right to vote but you
don't have any right for your vote to be
counted which
I suppose we've seen some examples of
that in recent years
so now I don't know exactly where this
stands I mean we're not going to edit
the movie we're not going to back down
we're we're going to put the shows on
Twitter we'll see what they do about
that and we're gonna we're gonna host
the movie so tune in tonight uh we're
going to be put putting this movie up at
8 pm Eastern we'll say if they want to
limit us for hate speech because we call
boys boys and girls girls okay I mean
that's fine it's hard for me to believe
that Elon is aware of this I would like
to believe that this is just getting
caught up in the middle management
holdover apparatchik Libs at Twitter who
don't want a basic message about truth
and nature and reality to get out I I
hope Elon comes in and intervenes here I
hope this hasn't just been a big
show a big a big performance but but
actually you know the libs are still
going to censor conservatives I hope I
hope it hasn't all been a lie but anyway
we're gonna put the movie up tonight
we're going to be on Twitter if they
suppress us they suppress us okay we'll
figure something else out we're not
going to lie about nature we want to
restore some balance
to our understanding of Nature and when
you want to do that you need to check
out balance of nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles living a healthy lifestyle is
not always easy especially when you're
always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure you're
getting the proper nutrition every day
which is why I'm a huge fan of balance
of nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to ensure you're
getting essential nutritional
ingredients daily their capsules are
packed with 100 whole food that you can
take at any time balance of nature uses
a cold vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
studio for our team to try and these
dirty rotten Jackal hyenas just took all
of them they just pounced they just
pounced and they restored balance to
their bodies but it's sometimes
difficult to claw over them and get get
them for me too go to
balanceofnature.com right now use promo
code noleskin wlas for 35 off your first
order is a preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
for 30 35 percent off your first order
balance of nature.com promo code Knowles
what a way to start pride month wow
I think the libs are focusing especially
on the most conservative or open to
conservative kind of platforms and
industries in particular because they
know they've already got the the ones
that have gone far left
so there are some places Twitter now
says okay we're going to be open to
conservatives I think the libs are going
to Target that even I think about sports
the only sport I like is Major League
Baseball
it's the only I don't even follow it in
recent years I tried to cancel my MLB TV
subscription I just don't really know
how to do it so I think I still
subscribe but but after they embraced
BLM I said okay I'm done with MLB I'm
not watching baseball this year and that
was some years ago now but baseball
remains pretty conservative it's
America's pastime it's a complicated
traditional sport it's one that Still
Remains a favorite of that most derided
hated group in society
straight white males we still sort of
like baseball it's it's a sport that
still has manly normal guys of of all
backgrounds playing it and so the libs
are really focusing on that and you saw
this with the Toronto Blue Jays you saw
this with Anthony bass who came out and
he he made a post that was critical of
pride
and he felt the weight of the liberal
establishment on him and I'm sorry to
say he just came out and apologized
I recognized yesterday I made a post
that was hurtful to the pride Community
which includes friends of mine and close
family members of mine Pride community
and I'm truly sorry for that
um I just spoke with my teammates took
and shared with them my actions
yesterday I apologize with them and as
right now I'm using the Blue Jays
resources to better educate myself to
make better decisions moving forward
the ballpark is for everybody we include
all fans at the Ballpark and we want to
welcome everybody that's all I have to
say thank you
pathetic what the hell is the pride
Community when did we start using that
phrase The Pride Community we're not
even referring now to guys who are a
little light in the loafers or lesbians
or anything no it's the pride Community
I've said it before I'll say it again
I'm from New York I lived in La for a
long time I'm a graduate of the gayest
University in the history of the world
a disproportionate number of my friends
and loved ones have some Divergent
eccentric sexual identities okay
I don't think any of them
even the ones who are
engaging in liberace-like Behavior I
don't think any of them would ever
describe themselves as members of The
Pride Community I don't think they would
take that identity on themselves
pride is the deadliest of the seven
deadly sins
Pride goeth Before Destruction and a
haughty spirit before a fall Pride this
Rainbow Coalition is a denial of reality
it's it's extraordinarily corrosive
to society it's it's offensive to all
people of decency
the vast majority of Americans
regardless of their sexual desires or
eccentricities don't want to be
inundated with with three-month-old
rainbow onesies when they walk into
Target and yet
a relatively manly normal guy playing
America's favorite pastime albeit up in
America's Top Hat up there in Canada
even those guys now have to bend the
knee for what for what man
this
reaction from Anthony bass here it
it it makes me check in on myself
it makes me check in I don't mean just
to castigate this guy but it reminds me
before the passion of Our Lord
Saint Peter spokesman of the Apostles
first among the apostles he says oh I
would never deny you Lord
and his Lord guy who he knows is God the
son who he has seen transfigured on a
mountain
he says oh Peter you're going to deny me
three times before the grows and
Peter says no I wouldn't I would never
do that what are you talking about
that's crazy I I would never do that
thing and then what happens the minute
the pressure gets hot even Peter denies
it
for what what was the post that this guy
Anthony
put out this is the post for pride month
he puts out here's the reason biblically
why I believe Christians ought to be
boycotting Target and Bud Light and any
other Corporation that's pushing the
things they're pushing I think a lot of
people make this into a political issue
or they say oh what's the big deal if
you know is it really going to make that
big of a difference if I'm shopping
there or not shopping there here's what
the Bible says it tells us what to do as
Christians in Ephesians chapter five it
says this take no part in the unfruitful
works of darkness but instead expose
them for it is shameful to even talk of
the things that they do in secret so
what does that mean to take no part well
what's Target do it's a business they
they make money they sell things and
they take part in that is to take part
in that God of Mammon that they're
serving and to take part in the darkness
that they're purveying and getting out
to the world and and shoving into
children's faces and to take part in
that is to give them your money and I
believe the Bible gives us radical
precedent to say no we are running from
that into an extend instead expose those
things to to shout it to all the people
that have ears to hear that this is evil
this is demonic we won't stand for it
we're not going to go to the stores
anymore and we're not going to give them
our money we're going to let our voice
be heard so that people can see the
light and so that people can be pulled
out of the darkness
unless Blue Jays management calls me and
tells me to apologize in which case
never mind forget I posted it what's
amazing about that post is it's not just
some vague kind of hint that he doesn't
like the pride month displays this is
pretty clear this is pretty intense
stuff this guy this blue jay saw this
post and said oh that speaks to me and
I'm a Christian and I I believe in this
and so I'm going to post it out there
I'm really not disparaging this guy even
Saint Peter denied our Lord three times
before the group
but
it's a reminder for all of us the
pressure is going to be very very
intense you're going to see it at your
job you're going to see it at school
you're going to see it with your friends
you're going to see in your neighborhood
you're going to see at your local coffee
shop it's going to be everywhere
we should all pray that we can stand
firm when that pressure comes down
because this is a very very intense
campaign we're only on day one of it I
know we've just had pre-pride month
you've seen the rainbows for a while now
and in the same way that that shops
start marketing Valentine's Day starting
in December these days you you've been
seeing this for a while
you better pray that you can stand firm
here
because this is
overtaking the culture
you've seen this play out even in the
way people are thinking about themselves
a an underreported trend
that's been going on for almost 20 years
now
Google searches about sexual orientation
and gender identity have spiked in the
last 20 years last 19 years
those searches have gone up by 1300
percent since 2004 according to an
analysis from the cultural currents
Institute and these questions include
things like am I gay am I lesbian am I
trans including also the word non-binary
and some of the even newer terms
this seems to pose a problem for the
pride ideology because for the question
am I gay am I lesbian am I Trans Am I
this am I that
isn't that something you're supposed to
know
don't The Pride people tell us that
that's something that you know
intrinsically from the moment that
you're not just a teenager not just a
child from the moment you're two years
old oh my little Johnny he picked up a
Barbie doll once that's how we knew that
he knew deep down that he was really a
girl so then why are some people
confused by this
why are some people am I lesbian am I
gay am I the first time I put on Warby
Parker glasses and I had a Blazer on I
looked in the mirror I said am I a
lesbian am I I don't I've seen a
representation of this on a liberal
Cable News Channel am I no I didn't
wonder that I know that I'm
I know that I'm not those things
but it raises this question is there a
social contagion aspect to the pride
ideology and the various sexual
identities that go along with it
right now more than one in five Zoomers
identify as lgbtq plus this is a
a bit of a spike from the historical
Norm of about one percent of people who
would identify with one of these sexual
identities how'd that happen
few options either There's Something In
The Water turning the frick consumers
gay Alex Jones totally Vindicated or
people just naturally are largely gay we
don't know what the top on that is let's
what is it 50 50 of people are secretly
gay or trans or whatever any of the
other elementop letters are
and they just didn't know it they just
discovered it or it's a social Contagion
or on that third point
sex and Beyond sex identity generally is
a complex concept that derives in part
from nature and in part from nurture and
Import in part from reason and impart
from the enactment of the will in
accordance with reason or against reason
that it's a little bit more complex than
the ideologues would have us believe
and and the more that one goes down this
sort of rabbit hole the more identities
spring up that's why they add 10 genders
it seems every single week now is
because the more that one focuses on
fantasies or aberrant desires or novel
identities
the more they seem to appear
what does that even mean what does it
mean to be lesbian or trans or gay or
any of these things
it would seem that as these searches are
exploding and people are are saying in
fact we've talked about it on this show
we've interviewed people about this
we've played videos of people who say oh
I wasn't trans but then I watched this
weird kind of pornography and then I
became trans some of the some of the
most prominent trans voices have said
this about themselves
Cynthia Nixon
who's an actress who ran for office she
said I wasn't a lesbian I just sort of
became a lesbian I adopted that identity
later on well that would undercut the
Born This Way argument but it doesn't
it it doesn't really matter what the
argument is it doesn't matter what the
justification is
you'll notice the libs always change the
arguments in the justification uh some
people are born this way no actually
you're not born anyway not only is your
sexual desire or not immutable but not
even your sex is immutable and no
transgender people their bodies are that
of a man but their souls are that of a
woman no actually forget about the soul
that that's not real their brains are
the brains of a woman even though your
brain's part of your body but hey never
mind forget about the explanation forget
about reason forget about argumentation
the conclusion is always the same
don't do normal stuff
do aberrant stuff you're going to see
this with the pride campaign from
Planned Parenthood the arguments for
abortion they always change they often
contradict abortion is a necessary evil
it should be safe legal and rare no
abortion is a good thing no abortions
morally insignificant notes that
whatever the argument though the
conclusion is always the same kill your
baby
that it's not just about the LGBT stuff
that's prominent now because we've
entered into the the rainbow month but
it's true of all of the the left-wing
liberal agenda all of their political
goals they don't care about the
arguments
argument reasoning be damned they're
going to get what they want not through
reason not through facts not through
logic through sheer tyranny of will
now when you want to exercise your will
in accordance with reason in a way that
will allow you to flourish in your
friends to flourish let's say you're
hosting a barbecue you got to check out
cinch right now go to cinch.com use
promo code Knowles you picture that
perfect summer night you imagine the
warm breeze on your face as you Lounge
in your favorite chair outside the grill
is sizzling with those Juicy Burgers the
aroma of food is irresistible your mouth
Waters as you wait for it to be cooked
to Perfection now
imagine what this perfect summer night
would have looked like if you went to
turn on the grill and your propane tank
was empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule and requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere go online to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks with promo
code Knowles kwles cinch.com download
the Cinch app promo code nulls to get
your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks limited time offer you must live
within a cinched service area to redeem
it cinch cynch.com offer for details yes
or no
is not just a game
yes or no is the internet's favorite
interview show
they're telling me many people are
talking about it okay it's so clear
but it's still a game
and you can pre-order your copy right
now
go to dailywire.com shop
there is a rumor
perhaps a conspiracy theory that the
pre-order is ending soon
so don't say I didn't warn you don't say
I didn't tell you so
if you are not able to secure a copy in
this next batch
we ordered the initial run was like a
thousand copies sold out in a Flash we
ordered many thousands more that also
sold out very very quickly so we're
doing it again you got to pre-order do
not miss your chance to cause
controversy and to reveal the true
positions of your friends and family
when it comes to the most hotly debated
topics and titillating conversations of
our time
speaking of titillating we just released
an episode with my friend Sean Spicer
former White House Press Secretary if
you haven't seen it already here's a
spicy little teaser
it's not
we're gonna have some words it's not
about the size of the crowd it's the
angle you photograph it from
there is more in the works for yes or no
coming soon I wish I could tell you what
is in the works for it I wish I could
affirm
what some of the conspiracy theorists
are saying about it but
until that time sees your opportunity
while you can go to daily wire.com shop
today
Virginia Department of Health is
celebrating the beginning of pride month
by promoting an organization called
queer kid stuff
make this up you couldn't write this in
a Hollywood script but the villainous
government Department that's trying to
queer all the kids
you'd say okay we're going to call the
program queer kid stuff oh no that's a
little too on the nose come on go back
make it more subtle well you can't
that's the reality of it
the Virginia Department of Health is
promoting an online chat service
marketed to minors
to teenagers who identify as lgbtq plus
what do they say queer kid stuff kid is
right there in the name it's an lgbtq
plus and Social Justice website for kids
and families the site includes links to
helpful resources videos and more
according to the Virginia Department of
Health it's not called queer family
stuff it's not being marketed to parents
it's being marketed to little kids
and I don't just want to get on my high
horse and moralize and scold everybody
and simply point out how evil this is
and the sort of evil that these
government apparatchics are doing
because you've got to see it from their
perspective
it's very helpful to see things from the
perspective of your opponents and
enemies sometimes from their perspective
this is a really good thing
because it's good to be trans it's good
to be LGBT elementop it's a really good
thing
according to them
whether it's innate and immutable
whether it's just an identity that you
develop over time whatever it is this is
the good identity this is the nice happy
one with the rainbow the other
identities you know getting married
having children Chicken in every pot two
cars in every garage that's bad that's
that's repressive that's all the wives
will hate that and the children will
grow up with pathologies and the men are
going to be awful patriarch domineering
Potter familias it's just bad oh that's
like 1950s stuff in 1950 I was bad so we
got to stop people from doing that we've
got to break up redefine abolish our
conception of what family is for this
new wonderful beautiful rainbow thing
it's good and these poor kids who they
grow up in these stifled awful
conservative traditional patriarchal
environments they don't they're secretly
deep down their true selves or LGBT and
we the the Valiant Heroes at the
Virginia Department of Health we've got
to break through the oppressive evil
structures of the family and the
political order and all of tradition to
help these sweet little Rainbow Children
break free from those shackles and that
oppression
that's what they think they might not be
able to articulate it that clearly but
that is what is motivating a lot of
their behavior they think they're the
good guys
that's their vision of the good and what
do the conservatives say in response to
that
nothing pretty much what you what do
conservatives say in response to that we
say hey
LGBT is great we love that but just
don't trans the kids
for some reason even though it's all
great it's all really good we're not
that there's anything wrong with that
we're so happy about that but just don't
but for some reason it's bad when you do
the tea part to a 17 year old you got to
wait until well okay maybe a
seven-year-old when they turn eight then
you can teach it to them in schools but
not but that part's bad we
or the ones who are a little more
serious about it they'll say we need to
break the T off from the LGB LGB without
the T
I get it I know you want to be a nice
guy you've got a gay cousin and you
don't you don't want to offend your gay
cousin even though your gay cousin might
very well actually agree with you and
the conservatives on this point but
you're afraid of being offensive you
want to be a nice guy okay
you can't break the tea away from the
LGB because they both derive from the
same false anthropology and that false
anthropology actually also is
incorporated into feminism the false
anthropology is that men and women are
interchangeable I've said it before I
won't belabor the point
the premise of LGBT
qia even the a part even the asexual
part is that there is no
Norm of
sexual behavior and identity that we
ought to encourage other than don't do
anything that's normal other than don't
follow the tradition other than that
though there's no Norm that we're
supposed to
follow the premise of
lgbtq including the a including the
asexual including all of them is that
men and women aren't real natural
distinct complementary categories
they're just interchangeable they don't
really mean anything at all men and
women there's no real difference maybe
they look a little bit different but
these days they don't even look all that
much different
and from that premise
you have to redefine marriage
because if
if you believe that men and women are
pretty much interchangeable
and two men is the same thing as two
women is the same thing as a man and a
woman in holy matrimony
and if that's true
then it's not a far leap to say okay
well if men and women are basically
interchangeable they're pretty much the
same then yeah man can become a woman of
course you can't
you can't break this apart it is a kind
of an internally consistent ideology
albeit an illogical one and then
especially if you're gonna say okay this
is all good men and women are
interchangeable men secretly can be
women born in the wrong body and there's
no standard of sexual identity or
behavior and we can't know even what we
really are who what our identity is man
is body and soul uh our our sex our
gender derives from our body so we can
actually know it from our body but it's
bigger than just our body women women
are not just X chromosomes in the uterus
but they're at least X chromosomes in
the uterus if you throw all that out
then you get to this really pathetic
part which is okay well just don't do it
to the kids why not
why not if it's good and it's true then
of course we should allow the kids to
engage in that
that totally gives the Libs The Pride
people the upper hand then that makes
the Virginia Department of Health look
good
ironically at least to some
the only way that you can make a clear
argument that will be in any way
respectable that will suggest that
you're a serious person who is
charitable who doesn't hate anybody who
loves everybody but who just wants to
say the truth in love is if you say not
the whole Rainbow Coalition has just got
it a little bit wrong and people get
things wrong they're not evil people
necessarily but it's just it's just not
it's just not
true okay
we've got to be clear in our messaging
and in our campaign now moving on there
will be plenty to say about the rainbow
month the rest of this month moving on
to other campaigns
Ron DeSantis is continuing on the
campaign Trail he has honed in on one
argument that's really strong
which is Trump gave the country over to
fauci I didn't do that
Trump then disputes desantis's handling
of kovitz says actually you did shut
your state down for a little while but
so you know you weren't perfect about it
but it's true DeSantis did open up
Florida
before a lot of other places did and
DeSantis has a great answer to Trump
which is hey if I was such a bad
Governor especially during covid why did
you move your whole family down to
Florida during my governorship
so you talked about uh changing her tone
a little bit with when we're president
Trump I don't believe you mentioned him
here by name tonight but does this mean
you're going to be a bit more aggressive
with campaigning against him so look I'm
going to respond to
attacks I mean if if you say Cuomo did a
better job with covid than Florida did
first of all that's not what he used to
say this is like new like six months ago
he would have never said that right he
used to say how great Florida was hell
his whole family moved to Florida under
my governorship are you kidding me
that's a good line
now of course Trump has had a presence
in Florida for a long time he obviously
bought the Mar-A-Lago club a long time
ago as the winter white house from the
beginning of Trump's presidency but it's
a good line he spent a lot more time in
Florida
and he moved a lot of his family and
interests down to Florida for a whole
host of reasons saving money on taxes
Better Business climate I assume part of
it because the state was opened up in
ways that say New York was not more more
amenable to Trump and and his way of
life that's all true I like that that's
a good line from DeSantis
my my only criticism of that press
conference there was not anything
DeSantis said but it's what was on his
his little placard right up front
on that placard it says text freedom to
512-345
I like freedom
big fan of freedom but freedom is one of
these words
that in recent years has been redefined
down to nothing Freedom can mean
anything to anyone in our modern world
the libs think that they're pursuing
Freedom the Communists think they're
pursuing Freedom the Libertarians think
they're pursuing Freedom the
traditionalists think they're everyone
everyone thinks he's for freedom
freedom is a very abstract concept
traditionally understood freedom is the
right to do what we ought to do Freedom
did not mean doing whatever you want
whenever you want to do it it's not what
our founding fathers thought about it
it's not what any serious thinker in
history has ever thought of freedom but
that view does prevail today including
among many quarters of the right
Ron DeSantis should not be
basing his campaign on a slogan of
Freedom that is not going to work that
seems stale that seems vague it seems
wishy-washy and Squishy it seems like
the old establishment line and it's not
what he has excelled at as governor and
it's not what could push him over the
Finish Line If Ron DeSantis is going to
win this Republican primary he's going
to win it by offering something new and
fresh and young and exciting and
different responding to a real need from
people and people today are not
complaining because they don't have
sufficient Freedom people don't even
really know what Freedom means anymore
we've got we've got a lot of freedom
right now to do drugs we've got a lot of
freedom right now to do weird sex stuff
we've got a lot of freedom right now to
move across borders without being
checked we've got a lot of freedom right
now
of private corporations to destroy our
Public Square we gotta we got a lot of
freedom okay we don't suffer from a
dearth of Freedom at least as the modern
liberals mean it what we suffer from is
a lack of order what we what we suffer
from is a lack of coherence what we
suffer from is a lack of of acceptance
of reality
okay that's what we need
one of the criticisms of the Trump
campaign is that he's been a little too
laissez-faire when it comes to some of
these issues
the best parts of the Trump campaigner
when he says no we're going to impose
some more restrictions on trade we're
going to put some more restrictions on
immigration we're going to post some
more restrictions on the weird sex
Behavior we're gonna
because again paradoxically
you can only have true freedom
by accepting restrictions you can only
have freedom of poetry when you
recognize that you need meter and rhyme
schemes and order to your poetry that's
what opens up creativity when you take
away all the limitations you end up with
slam poetry which is the death of art
it's no Freedom at all it's just
babbling incoherence
you have political Freedom when you
recognize that there are limitations to
sex nature the family the basic
political unit the community borders
that's the only way you can have
political freedom is when you recognize
there's a limitation called the border
around your country that gives you the
citizens a special rights and privileges
that distinguish you from the rest of
the world if you don't recognize that
limitation then you don't have a nation
you certainly don't have any national
freedom
DeSantis probably wants to run away
from being called an authoritarian I
know a lot no one wants to be called an
authoritarian or a tough order impose my
will on people yeah he doesn't want
that's what people want Trump won in
2016 by saying hey this free trade stuff
this total open free trade it hasn't
worked out well for a lot of people it
hasn't worked out well for America's
manufacturing base hasn't hasn't
actually worked out well for National
Security
the pro-freedom people said that if we
just Outsource everything to China we
give away our intellectual property and
our whole manufacturing base that'll
make us a little bit richer maybe it did
make some people a little bit richer
maybe it made GDP tick up but now when
we're facing a potential world war that
would involve China now we look pretty
weak and we look back to our founding
fathers we look back to Abraham Lincoln
who in many ways re-founded the country
all of these guys said no
having manufacturing here having some
restrictions that is a matter of
National Security that's That's
essential to a flourishing country
having borders is essential to a
flourishing country having prescriptions
limitations around your behavior
especially in the realm of sex and drugs
and all sorts of behavior That's
essential to your true Freedom founding
father said if you abuse your Liberty to
licentiousness you're going to lose
everything
this I it just it triggered me to see
DeSantis who's been a good governor and
he's run a decent campaign relatively
decent campaign thus far in difficult
circumstances to go back to this Freedom
we're just for Freedom it's just so
stale it's just okay if DeSantis is
going to run as just another one of
these establishment guys who says the
same old lines from 2006 okay but
Trump's definitely going to win that
that that's not even a question
if DeSantis wants to be able to
challenge the incumbent who's way up on
him in the polls he's going to need to
offer something a little bit different
he's going to have to know what time it
is and I think he does generally I think
a lot of people around him know what
time it is he's got to follow those
instincts and don't fall back to the
same old platitudes if DeSantis runs a
safe campaign he's completely toast his
only shot is to get a little provocative
his only shot is to
is to offer a choice not an echo Just As
Trump did in 2016. now if you're looking
for something interesting to watch you
got to check out the series what we saw
hosted by Storyteller Bill Whittle
season one is focused on Apollo 11. now
season two of what we saw is in full
swing in episode 12 a change of command
comes too late to reverse the situation
in Southeast Asia as Richard Nixon's
program of Vietnamization eases America
out of its worst directed War but long
before the last American serviceman
leaves Vietnam
a new generation of liberators rise to
the challenge of saving American tactics
weaponry and Doctrine from themselves
Bill makes you feel like you're there
witnessing history
hear this amazing story in this week's
episode of Cold War new episodes of The
Cold War come out every week you have
got to be a member to see it go to
dailywire.com Cold War to start watching
my favorite comment
yesterday is from Jacobi F who says
forget pride month I will be celebrating
the Sacred Heart of Jesus month which is
June that's true that is the month of
June month for the Sacred Heart of Jesus
and that's an important point it's not
just a point saying I'm going to be
Christian and not be a lib or something
it's an important point that
we conservatives need to offer a
positive vision
we need to offer not just things to hate
not just things to avoid but things to
love things to embrace things to engage
in this is why you are seeing in
Orthodox Christian circles especially in
the Catholic church
it's true of all sorts of denominations
that are relatively more Orthodox than
others but you're seeing this especially
in the Catholic church right now a vast
expansion an Embrace of the traditional
Latin Mass especially by young people
especially by converts especially by
reverts like myself
why is that still a small minority of
people in the Catholic Church who attend
the traditional Latin mass and it's
opposed by lots of people in high places
at the Vatican lots of Boomers who don't
want going back to who don't want us
going back to that old bad timing sort
of liturgy that existed for thousands of
years and this is the mass of the ages
but why are young people flocking to
that
because it gives you something beautiful
deep rich full of symbolism something to
love something to venerate
something to do with your body it's
something to do to occupy your time when
if you just remained totally neutral you
would be swept away by The Winds of the
prevailing liberal culture that's what
conservatives have to do broadly we need
to offer people not just a vision of how
ugly the stuff that the libs are doing
is we need to also build up for people
and offer them a vision of beauty
now
I told you at the top of the show
no industry is going to be left
untouched by Pride that is true even of
the abortion industry here is the pride
campaign for Planned Parenthood
hi hi
my name is lucky I've had an abortion
and I get gender affirming care from
Planned Parenthood
I wound up in a very very difficult
relationship and within three months I
found out that I was pregnant I was like
oh no
my abortion was one of the greatest acts
of compassion I had ever committed it
was an easy decision and it was a
decision that for the friends I had told
I was trans they were like get it you
know that's fine like great you know
that's your decision you want to finally
begin your life and it was
good
just one of the best decisions I had
ever made
ever in my life
who's she trying to convince
the lady doth protest too much me thinks
when you make a good decision
do you need to constantly tell yourself
and everybody else what a good decision
that was
when you engage in behaviors that are
good for you and that allow you to
flourish
do you need to change your name to lucky
I don't know what her real name is but
do you need to change your name to Lucky
happy fortunate oh me I'm happy that's
my new name I used to be Michael but now
I'm happy because of how happy I am I'm
so happy it was I've made all the best
decisions I don't have any regrets no
not me no I'm so happy are the cameras
rolling yes I'm still very very happy
I'm not really persuaded by that
I'm not persuaded this poor woman
has
[Music]
maybe if I just do one more video for
Planned Parenthood about how happy I am
maybe then I'll really be happy
does that look like a flourishing person
I don't think so and then Planned
Parenthood posts this with a comment
says
when it comes to your abortion any
reason is the right reason
gives away the game right there telling
your abortion story is important and the
more we talk about this essential form
of Health Care the more normalized it
becomes thank you for sharing lucky it
it does become somewhat more normalized
it does become somewhat more accepted
that's true that's how culture works
but it never becomes good it never
becomes right it can never totally shut
out
the moral conscience
we know most of maybe all of us know at
some level but most of us know a pretty
visceral level this is really wrong and
you can normalize it and you can put
rainbows on every single building and
you can have planned parenthood ads
blaring from all the TV screens
you can't change that reality you can't
shut out that the Beating Heart
underneath the floorboard in the Edgar
Allan Poe story you can't
That's The Telltale Telltale Heart
that's the The Telltale
moral conscience that you've got that
that's going to
that's that's going to show you the
truth
any reason is the right reason for an
abortion any reason
any reason what if it's that you hate
men you hate men
and you found out that your baby is a
boy and so you want to kill the the baby
boy because you hate men so much that is
actually an acceptable reason for an
abortion now and people do it and
doctors perform it
what if it's this what if it's that you
hate black people and you you know
you've got your you have you're a woman
you have sex with a black person and so
you know your baby's going to be black
and you just you you hate black people I
mean you really I don't know maybe you
got too drunk one night you slept with
this but you really you seriously hate
black people so you found out your kid's
black and so you want to you want to
kill your child because he's black and
you want to kill a black person
that could be a reason for an abortion
would that be the right reason according
to Planned Parenthood that would because
any reason's the right there's no wrong
wrong reason to have an abortion
what if you want to have an abortion
because you believe as many many people
throughout history have believed that
there are demons and you can Curry favor
with Demons by sacrificing uh innocent
people and especially sacrificing babies
widespread practice throughout the
entire world for most of human history
including today by the way
would that be a good reason that's a
good reason to oh yes I want to have an
abortion to uh Curry favor with the dark
lord of the Netherworld would that be a
good reason according to Planned
Parenthood I know it sounds ridiculous
to many modern people that's what
they're saying
the reasons always change the conclusion
is always the same kill your baby
when any argument can lead you to a
certain
conclusion a certain dark conclusion
that should throw up your warning signs
that should have the sirens blaring whoa
watch out here we're not dealing with
reality this is not logical there's dark
stuff going on
and you're seeing it throughout the left
any any reason is a reason to sterilize
yourself and chop off your genitals and
pump yourself full of poison any reason
is good or whether you think you're born
that way you think you became that way
or you watched a bunch of porn or
whatever it is any reason just trans
yourself just castrate yourself
just chop your body up just kill your
baby
the voice that is speaking to you and
telling you that that's not the voice of
the Holy Spirit that's not the voice of
your moral conscience that's a very
different voice and it's a voice that
you should block out
might be it might be multiple voices
might be a legion of voices some some
might suggest okay I guess also there's
some sports thing going on not baseball
but I guess basketball or something so
anyway Ben Davies who's like a big buff
athlete guy he uh wants to see if I can
guess any NBA logos is there what is it
it's basketball season I guess what do I
know the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member at dailywear.com
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign